[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants mon petit doigt me
dit qu'aujourd'hui vous avez été très
agitée est ce que c'est vrai voyons
comment ça se fait que pas trop seul
premier rang vive
c'est le 1er avril bruit mais alors vous
avez fait des blagues
moi en tout cas on m'en fait pas des
blagues en nombre au nom on m'en fait
pas des blagues
parce que je l'air sérieux et bien nous
allons voir cela est bon
[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants qu'est ce que ça va
être bon jeu au pied du repos mais
qu'est ce que c'est que ça premier
league en tic octobre
lui le petit coquin
[Musique]
fort
ou non alors non pas moi un bon poisson
d'avril à un p'tit louis au delà voilà
alors que chercher à faire alors mais
bon bon bon bon bon puisque c'est comme
ça alors à mirabel oiseaux bavards
on veut qu'elle compte encore mais je ne
veux pas que ce poisson là moi me
annonce mais j'en ai assez à la fin de
ce poisson au val bas alors non ko
puisque c'est comme ça je vais la porter
à ulysse a aisni voulait à ulysse le
bien aussi il aura son poisson d'avril
on n'a jamais autant bien sûr le
j'arrive pas trop à nous donc m'évite de
nuit petit force
[Musique]
louis alibert fois son mari
onu et p'tit louis monier mirabel au
nuit les petits enfants en dormez vous
vite
c'était une belle journée
on a fait beaucoup de blagues on a ri
et maintenant on va vite au lit alors
bonjour tu te dépêches je ris alors
allons en route mon vieux nounours et à
demain romain
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh